so elon musk tweeted in the past i voted
democrat because they were mostly the
kindness party but they have become the
party of division and hate so i can no
longer support them and will vote
republican now watch their dirty tricks
campaign against me unfold and he also
then tweets political attacks on me will
escalate dramatically in coming months
yep
what do you guys think
does it matter
is it something we all have experienced
ourselves and know already i think one
thing that it shows is how far to the
left the republican party has actually
moved yeah it's substantially to the
left of what it used to be and you can
tell because people like elon musk are
going to vote republican after a
lifetime of
voting democrat i'm essentially a
conservative because the democrats have
gone so far to the left and i stayed
right here and the republicans came over
and i was like oh hey fellas exactly no
it's true and i hear so many people say
that the only time i've ever heard
someone say something along the lines of
i'm on the left just because the
republican party's going so far right is
when they're on corporate media and
they're some rhino right right it's like
oh no one in real life says that ever
it's like
16 year olds that's not true 60 year old
millionaire warmonger who's like i don't
know i don't recognize my party anymore
yes the democrats want to blow up kids
in the middle east so i'm going to vote
for them it's like okay that's why i
won't that's why i won't yeah exactly
it's the same i'm super conflicted on
elon musk continuing to like evolve and
put his hands more into politics because
he's going to be another billionaire
potentially funding candidates in the
future he might be another peter thiel
type figure in the future so it'll be
interesting to see how he changes and
develops but i am highly
i wonder why he would fund any
politicians do you do well because he's
trying to get involved in politics or
one way or another and like twitter was
president right um i think he was
born but it wouldn't be worth it for him
to run he could just have his paws on
different elections and by funding
people but what i was trying to get to
in a full circle kind of way is that he
still has deep connections to china he
still has tesla factories in china and
he will still be at the whim of this
government the chinese government the
communist chinese government that is if
he does want to do any business there in
the future he needs to make sure he
doesn't step on any toes i know we kind
of overlooked that because uh musk has
become this sort of anti-left figure and
we don't know that we talk about all the
time
that elon musk has praised china on more
than one occasion he's got factories in
china sure but he's kind of become a
hero in some online anti-left circles
because he is a big voice willing to
come out against these people and it
seems as though all you have to do
nowadays to be get a lot of fans on
twitter and say the obvious that men
can't become women or something like
that so it's just p i think people ought
to be cautious who they end up
supporting being reactionaries against
others but if you think about saying men
can't become women on twitter a month
ago that would have gotten you banned
from the platform
uh
maybe maybe twitter's bands are it's a
it's a cast system the more followers
you have the more you can say
so i said i tweeted what did i tweet
don't cut off teenage girls tits
and uh someone reported me and then i
got an email from it's like from twitter
and i was like you've been reported
under german law or whatever and we
found no violation whenever i tweet
stuff like this people are like oh tim's
gonna get banned now and i'm like are
you kidding dude i got a million
followers not gonna ban me well the
babylon b got banned for saying that uh
oh i know rachel levine who's obviously
a man
yeah so if you say a generality then
they they gave you more leeway if you
have a small account like 100 followers
and you say you know men and women are
different or something they'll ban you
if you have a big account like the
babylon b and said men are different
they'd leave you alone but they said
rachel levine specifically is it too
cliche to say that double mastectomies
are modern day lobotomies almost in a
way well they don't i hear they don't
remove your brain they don't remove the
same thing but just as we look at back
on the bottom he's now sort of medical
malpractice is how in the future we will
look back
it's certainly an anti-mother operation
i think it's like a butchering it's like
the next stage of plastic surgery and
kind of a butchering of a body yeah
i don't want to i don't want to deviate
too far from what we were talking about
because we are going to talk about this
in just a second sure so you know
talking about elon and twitter sure wolf
around the top of elon i just want to
respond to what you said i totally agree
i've said this in the past i'm
cautiously optimistic about elon i'm not
totally sold and it's absolutely true
all someone has to say is i'm not
completely all the way on the far left
with respect to one single issue or i
think the left has gone too far here and
all of a sudden the right wing is all
over that person yeah and there's also a
lot of parallels between elon musk and
somebody who's commonly demonized bill
gates i mean these are both people who
had their come-ups in the tech industry
and some of the stuff elon musk says is
crazier than what bill gates says elon
musk is the chip planter well the
difference is though
elon musk bill gates romeo and juliet i
will say they're both billionaires
they're both you know the richest people
that existed during their time period
during the top but bill gates gets
demonized like no other and elon musk
becomes a hero of the same people well
the same people who will complain about
bill gates being some demonic you know
cabal man will praise elon musk for the
simplest things on twitter sure i want
to mention the broadway show though if i
if i may that's the broadway show nina
jankowicz plays elon musk
as juliet and
uh james o'keefe plays bill gates as
romeo so that's the show to your point i
hear in but so the reason i consider
myself cautiously optimistic about elon
musk but i don't like bill gates comes
down to really one really important
issue it's that bill gates has
repeatedly said things like there are
too many people in this world he's
discussed population control whereas
elon musk is basically the only ultra
wealthy person saying we need more
people
no i'm not i'm not a fan of the brain
chips yeah yeah exactly i'm not a fan of
the brain but i think it's gotten to the
point where there are so few elites
saying anything even remotely sane that
when one of them does it's a victory and
doesn't he have a bunch of kids yes i
know bill gates also has a history with
his like father supporting uh margaret
thatcher or sanger in the past
connections with planned parenthood but
i still think you know if you want to
extrapolate what elon musk says with the
brain chips it's just as bad as anything
i think bill gates has said
in particular so it's just i think it's
an interesting thing
about the brain chips
i think he said he's talking about
neural link yeah yeah so neural link is
i mean it's a pretty fascinating tool
and if it's used properly i think it
would really help people who are
disabled
okay
right right so one of the things it can
help do is people who have spinal
injuries it can help connect their brain
to other parts of the body and bill
gates is trying to cure different
diseases
so that's why this is a moot point my
question is elon musk is going to force
the chip into people's brains well
offering up a service that you don't
like and don't think is creepy is bad we
can criticize it people who do bad
things but the the question
around
here is around freedom bill gates has
called for rescinding freedoms saying
how is how is elon gonna stop
misinformation you can't do this he said
we need less people and bill gates said
that and elon musk said we actually need
more people to stay in the planet and
people should have freedom of speech now
the things they work on we can criticize
but when we're specifically talking
about elon and things we like it's for
the things we like and when we criticize
them it's for the things we don't like
and the end result i believe is
supporting freedom of speech
and and defending the rights of humans
or saying people are good and we need
more of them
will probably create a better outcome in
the long run no matter what he works on
in terms of neuralink bill gates saying
the opposite is darkness that will lead
us on a very dark path of death and
suffering yeah i actually totally agree
with that and i do
i do like this idea that we need more
people because
we need people to support the people
that already exist and we need to create
more resources
um and human beings are the best
resource the planet has i i don't
completely agree
that um you know we've talked about
overpopulation
and there are a lot of people who say
actually let me try and find google
earth
there are a lot of people who say that
um
we're not overpopulated
uh and is that that's an opinion i think
you guys have right yeah have you ever
looked at a map of the united states
yes yes have you ever actually looked
and at down at the the level of
development in north america
like it's only really popping on the
coasts no i mean you can no no the
entirety everything when you look at
pull up look we've got when you say
development i mean like when when you
see pictures
where the lights are human altering
terrain doesn't matter where the lights
are grab illinois for instance and when
you zoom in basically the entirety of
the state has been developed there's
some pockets of trees in some state
parks but you can just
go straight through the state in any
direction and every little square is
human development why is that bad
so i'm not saying that's bad but i'm
certainly saying when the entirety of
illinois or other states are completely
developed we
overpopulation is something that i think
we should discuss or entertain well
shouldn't we then
people maybe should move to other places
they don't live there we've taken the
land and we've cut it and developed it
to produce a certain thing
so
perhaps we can say
maybe we're not overpopulated but we're
over producing
we are utilizing
massive swaths of
millions of you know acres or whatever
to produce all of this all the all this
food and all these resources that we're
consuming like crazy maybe if humans
consumed less
we might not have to worry about over
development we're shipping and
fertilizer from from europe norman
borlaug has increased crop yield but
nutrient density has diminished
substantially so i i think as much as i
you know i respect elon musk saying
things like more people is better than
less people because when you say less
people really bad things happen yeah i
think we should try and make sure we're
having a legitimate conversation maybe
i'm wrong but i can point to a few
things that i think at least would need
to be questioned like the bug population
collapses
uh the debt the dead zones in in the in
the ocean fishery collapse and mass
pollution
maybe it's not overpopulation you know
we talked with michael mals about this
it may be
over pollution or over development or
something exactly so i think you hit the
nail on the head with that last
statement my issue with the idea of this
being an overpopulation issue framing
the narrative that way is that you are
with that framing indicating what the
solution has to be in your mind so it's
circular if you say we have an
overpopulation problem that we then what
you're effectively saying is the
solution is for there to be less people
right the salute well but but if you
point out the way you did that there
there are issues such as you know insect
populations declining if that's the case
or pollution then we ask the question
how can we deal with these problems and
there's no reason to believe the
solution is to get rid of people or have
less people i agree with that 100 i
think the solution is actually um
better agricultural technology and
development i believe it is culture i
think the united states has cultural
problems i think we all agree with that
yeah i think we have we have a culture
of gluttony instead of responsibility
amen i think that is a problem
absolutely so you have you have people
who are morbidly obese and instead of
being like maybe i should consume less
they're like this is fine actually let's
get on the cover of a magazine and tell
everyone else to live this way too i
think we have a parenting problem as
well because i think that parents don't
teach their children to be responsible
either for themselves or for others and
i think that that is a key thing to do
like children you know stop worrying
about what college your kids are going
to go to or what career they're going to
have and instead
teach your kids to grow up to be kind
responsible people
who can take care of themselves and the
people that they love
and who also want to i think that's what
so and find joy in it
yeah
yeah we i mean
i saw a post not long ago and you see a
lot of this from people saying things
like
you know so much of our life is
dedicated to work and i do believe that
at some point people can be overworked
100 and that's a problem but
they were saying things along the lines
of you know the only thing meaningful
about my life is when i'm off work and i
think a lot of that is firstly an issue
with the kinds of jobs people have now
there's a good argument to be made for
that but also that no one finds any
value in the service of others and
people don't take any pride in doing
things that make other people's lives
easier but the other thing too is that
we have completely diminished the value
of just doing work yeah right i mean if
there's a job worth doing and this is
cliche but there's a reason it's cliche
if there's a job worth doing it's worth
doing
as well as you possibly can you know i
there was recently i forget what it was
but sometimes there'll be like an
article at work and i'm going to be
writing it at post-millennial and
sometimes i think like you know i don't
really feel like writing this and then i
think okay if you don't feel like
writing it clearly you're missing
something clearly you're missing some
aspect of this story go figure it out do
some research investigate it find out
the interesting part of it and then
write it and whenever that happens oddly
those end up being my best pieces the
ones where i'm not sure at first and i'm
just kind of like eh and then i dig into
it and i'm like oh that's actually
fascinating and now i have a great piece
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you